how many dimensions officially are in
the CERN and they both said 17 very
affirmatively and then they started
talking about a portal there's a portal
for the LHC there's an open a round door
you know like in the Stargate in front
of the door they have a room and they
sit around the table and and I said so
oh yeah what happened he said well an
entity came out came from this portal
and and [music] like sat at the table
and they said this this entity the
second time took a scarf
and left a scarf. What type of scarf in
it? They don't know. They don't Top
scientists at the Large Hydron Collider,
LHC, says that the Titanic machine may
possibly create or discover on 8th of
April for the eclipse previously
unimagined scientific phenomenon or
unknown [music] unknowns. For instance,
an extra dimension who says out of this
door might come something or we might
send something [music] through it, but
that even with the power of the LHC at
his disposal, he would only be able to
hold it open a very tiny lapse of time.
But during that infinitisimal amount of
time, we would be able to peer into this
open door, either by getting something
out of it or sending something into it.
The name comes from Cernunos. Cernunos,
the the god of the um deer. And the deer
in Latin is Cunos, [music]
but it's an animal with horns. And
that's their cult. And during the
inauguration, our official politicians
were standing there looking at [music]
the CERN open door with angels and
demons going through it and very crazy
um naked, you know, looking naked dance
with horns on their heads.
>> What does she have to gain from saying
these things? The end is near, guys. And
I know that sounds crazy, but it also
sounds crazy that the military is on the
news saying, "Yeah, we talked to
interdimensional beings." And a
scientist is putting her reputation on
the line and saying, "The people at CERN
are telling me that things are coming
out of this portal and what is about to
happen in this world." And the Bible
says that the dragon is going to deceive
the entire world. That in the latter
times that many will depart from the
faith, meaning that they were Christian,
but they departed from the faith, giving
heed to seducing spirits. These demons
do not come out looking like monsters
trying to scare you. They're seductive.
They're like the snake in the garden
saying, "Eat this fruit. Your eyes will
be open. You'll be like God. And if
you're not founded on understanding what
prophecy is, you're going to be
deceived. Hands down. You're going to be
lost." We have to get in God's word
every single day. We have to be praying
and putting on the full armor of God. We
got to be asking for supernatural
protection. We are defenseless against a
powerful foe like Satan and all his
demons. We are nothing without the sword
of the spirit. the word of God and
prayer.
>> [music]